the lesson is here it got choose your
teachers wisely when the market crash in
2008 gets so much money I borrowed a lot
300 million no way from our investors
the banker how's that how does that work
because interest rates are dropping and
real estate prices were going to the
toilet and when I walk into my bank or
the split Rich Dad Poor Dad about this
airport has about a financial statement
ankle statement balance sheet statement
of cash flows a book on accounting
people don't even know it's a book on
accounting so I walked into my bank with
my partner that all this property of us
floating to the surface and I say I'll
take them off your hands
I just give me the money to buy the
property Wow that's the hottest 300
million give me the money and I'll buy
your property that's crazy
so it depends and this is my whole thing
I am now 700 million almost a billion in
debt premi you know why cuz I don't pay
any taxes the more Jenna I have the less
tax okay and the average guy goes how do
you do that because you have bad
teachers and so it's this whole thing
that you got choose your teachers wisely
that's why I wrote the book fake fake
money fake teachers fake assets I didn't
touch that garbage eyeballs what's up I
don't have a 401k I don't have stuff on
there's a Fonzie ts doesn't mean you
shouldn't but I don't need them okay
right and the other part is look for
young guys the best teachers are not in
colleges the best teacher are on YouTube
the best teachers are on YouTube wake up
yeah this guy George gammon he's
fantastic
Patrick met David fantastic you know
he's great records the fake teachers are
in colleges they're telling to get a job
right the corporate ladder you know
Patrick Beck Davidson at the best and I
love that guy he says there's two kinds
of leaders
wartime and peacetime and a peacetime
leader is a garlic my poor debt he goes
through all the right schools here's all
the pedigrees adentro he does all the
right things he climbs the Corporal
ladder and all that well wartime leader
goes goes to war so Jobs Steve Jobs the
wartime leader I'm a wartime leader
difference is I went to war I went to
war twice on the frontlines yeah and I
check it what happened I so I joined the
Marine Corps got a flight full of
Pensacola I learned to fly but a camp
Pendelton I strapped on my weapons I go
to advanced weapons and camp Alton I go
to Okinawa and then they sent me into
Vietnam and I came out of Vietnam about
four months later back to back to
restage at Okinawa and I thought
everybody had changed I looked at the
fellow Marines I thought through and it
wasn't that they were I had been to war
mmm
you got tougher it's different when
someone's trying to kill you every
single mission I went down three times
no way yeah and I came back stronger and
tougher so I come back to Okinawa I got
like a week off and they gonna ship me
back into Vietnam again I said what
happened to these guys and it wasn't
that they change I changed so what
happens to entrepreneurs who go out and
they get their ass handed to them and
they survive if you survive you see the
world Circle minutes and that's what
happened to you when you get injured at
all this yeah you see a different world
whereas some peacetime who's climbing
the corporate ladder right now they just
lost their job they're sucking their
thumb you know this is the worst time
for yet for a wartime leader this we're
excited they're excited about it yeah
it's the best attempts yeah entrepreneur
right now the world is open to you
you're an employee your worlds dead to
you
what if ya an entrepreneur can create
their own success and for the people
that are the wartime people what is the
the best advice you would give them now
for the next year or two years to
capitalize on how do they make more
money how do they make their millions
during this time what would you get who
can't make money now you should hang it
up I tell all frickin Millennials man
where it is
I got this iPhone if you can't make
money with that
hang it up you know like we used to say
hang out the jockstrap
you know the team you can't make money
with an iPhone through social media
through marketing you have the world at
your fingertips and you can't make money
the problem is between this ear and this
year's out here it's in here that's why
you've got to choose your teachers
wisely yeah you know so let me just say
it again
the best teachers power on YouTube so
it's the best portal take up your mind
make up about what you want listen to
you know nice so I'm just being real I
hear you what's what's the best
investment people can make then to to
operate capitalizing this opportunity is
the investment in education left if
you're poor right now it was called look
in the mirror always said to me if
you're looking in the mirror right now
you see a loser that's what you are mmm
can't make money in this economy you
better change yeah I think you know
hindsight is 20/20 yes yes well if
you're looking at yeah you don't have
any money you don't have a job your
boyfriend or girlfriend has left you and
Sammy goes well how did I get here how
did I get here there's a great book
called you know Gulag Archipelago by
Solzhenitsyn so he gets thrown in this
in a concentration camp or a gulag in
Siberia
and he says how did I get here you know
how you got there because he was a
peacetime theater mmm-hmm
didn't fight back so people are being
sold about go to school get a job pay
taxes save money get out of debt buy a
house the house is an asset and invest
for the long-term in a well-defined
portfolio of stocks bonds mutual funds
and ETS and I do none of that and why do
you recommend the opposite
I don't have to do that Pratt that's
that's cool eight go to school go to
school look they teach you about money
nothing get a job you pay the highest
taxes pay your taxes I don't pay taxes
get out of debt well debt money is dead
after 1971 few additional money your
house is not an asset house is a
liability and why would an investment
long-term the stock market when I can
make my own assets I don't need the
stock market unless say you shouldn't
mm-hmm I create my own assets I create
my own cash flow every day you mean
through your business through your your
right your creativity I'm an
entrepreneur
yeah most people are employs 25 million
people unemployed in four weeks and the
number keeps going up unprecedented
unprecedented spike never in the history
of the United States of America have we
had this many people that go in this
short a period of time for those of you
who've been let go you were talking to a
guy that is an expert at being let go
I've been fired from six or seven jobs
the last job I was fired from six times
I have I have literally lost every job
to a firing that I ever had just so you
know and that doesn't count all the
customers that had fired me over the
years all the people that hired me and
were disappointed with me so this is a
tough time right now this is a crazy
crazy uncertain time you know right now
I'm gonna tell you what I go through
every day right now I'm gonna get into
the show but this is the roller coaster
that I'm on I'm on this roller coaster
right now and the roller coaster looks
like this
I'm not bragging about the roller
coaster because you don't want to be on
a roller coaster and life should not be
a roller coaster you shouldn't be
emoting like it's like this it's like
this right now okay okay I go through
okay it's gonna be all right
I'm positive and then I'm like depressed
and then I'm going down right here oh my
god how long is this gonna last and then
I get optimistic again and then I get
into fear start gunk coming up again see
some bad news
oh my god see even that even my damn pen
doesn't work okay
I get excited about so I'll go up I'm
like oh my god everything's gonna be
fine in a Wham I get the press cuz it's
a bad news then I go up again I'm like
okay we're everything's gonna we're
gonna get on the other side of this I
know we're gonna get on the other side
of this I keep trying to play this trick
on my head and then which by the way
it's true we are gonna get to get on the
other side of this and then I get hit
with like uncertainty and like oh my god
how long is it gonna last so I'm gonna
be talking about the day that today if
you've been let go look I know what that
feels like
you you know when you when you get left
go from a job what happens first is oh
my god am I not good enough am i am i
you know they didn't like me like it's
personal forget the money for a second
then the money gets then you get hit
with the second shot about the money and
it's like okay well I'm no good they let
me go but they kept other people and
then it's like oh I don't have any money
so you get hit with this double whammo
right and then and then and then you
feel sorry for yourself the third one is
like you go into it probably some some
grief because of the loss fear because
of the money uncertainty because of the
future so I want to help you I want to
help you if you've lost your job in I
understand what it feels like I was the
top performer at a company the last two
companies I lost jobs with I was the top
performer there and lost jobs in both
companies and I'm like wait a minute
why am I losing my job and both in both
cases this is when the economy was good
so even even when you lose a job when
the economy is good you still got to
reboot
you still got to figure out where am I
going again their uncertainties there
the money
fears there I'm not good enough I'm not
gonna be able to make it how long am I
gonna be out of work so here's the rules
okay right now America is showing some
compassion to people out of work I think
you get 32 weeks can somebody look it up
how many weeks of unemployment can I get
25 million people have filed for
unemployment the $600 just just so
everybody knows the $600 only lasts for
13 weeks 13 weeks is what four months
four months four months and one week
four plus one for the six hundred bucks
so maybe maybe you're gonna get I think
in California it's like $54,000 a year
but see that's what you see in the media
but the truth is it's not gonna last a
year folks thirty two weeks a in a year
fifty two weeks is a year how much is it
Johnny oh oh sorry sure you only get 26
weeks of benefit twenty-six and half of
that half of that is is for the six
hundred bucks so I know some of you
right now thinking oh it's not gonna be
that bad I know some people that lost
their job and said oh this is actually a
pay raise for me I'm like what are you
crazy
you just lost your purp you're why you
just lost the place to go to everyday
okay I'm gonna tell you right now I
would rather work for nothing did not
work everybody watching this show today
would you rather work for nothing
post it in comments would you rather
work for nothing or would you rather
work for a what your work you're like
I'm not working for nothing
everybody this quarantine is working for
nothing right now if you're at home
right now and you have nothing to do
you're working for nothing nobody's
paying you right now human beings on
this planet wake up every day with no
work every single day of the year how do
you get back to work
I want you to ask the wind the what and
the why when do you get back to work
today
don't leave your job if you lost your
job go back and get the job back don't
lose two things don't lose the money and
the job I don't know why people leave a
job right now it's insane to me okay
you're at Starbucks you leave some money
there and the coffee you left the money
don't leave the thing you went for okay
you got a job the company had to cut you
you like the place you work at or you
wouldn't have taken the job I think you
liked it if you didn't like the job
maybe you were let go because you didn't
like the job maybe this is the moment to
pivot if you left if you took a job and
you loved the job and the company had to
cut you so they could stay in business
don't leave the job just leave the money
you get it now you got to put your ego
aside to do
you cannot be emotional to do this
you've got to be completely analytical
don't lose the title the job the purpose
the mission and the money go back go
back okay go back some of you that I had
to let go you shouldn't have left don't
leave
say hey man I'll do it for nothing I'll
prove my value if you were going to go
into the NBA the NFL the MLB the the NHL
if you're gonna become an actor or an
actress in Hollywood you're gonna write
for Hollywood Steven Spielberg I
guarantee you're gonna do it for nothing
in the beginning like everybody needs to
get over there the the emotional and be
completely logical get over the heart oh
god Lee that wasn't fair do life ain't
fair life is brutal life is hard
if you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable continue to believe and I'll
see you there but I try to make sure
everyone's doing right now is be more
productive